[Musik]
glauben wir müssen was tun ich bin
einfach genervt dass nichts getan wird
und nutze diese veranstaltung um da
einfach mal kunst zu tun dass das
scheiße
man weiß ja was passieren würde dass es
auch uns betreffen kann aber es ist eher
werden so an die jüngere generation war
und dass wir quasi die generationen sind
ich sagen wie man muss weil für die an
den kanzler stellt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich stehe hier an der alten brücke
und heute dienst gerade bund regungen
statt der drei fahrstreifen
seit dem frühen morgen sind die
demonstranten statt
ganze straßenzüge und straßen kreuzungen
blockiert und vielen autofahrern den weg
zur arbeit ganz schön und sprechchöre
sind unter anderem konzerne aber
natürlich die suv fahrer kommen hier
nicht gut weg die stimmung ist insgesamt
friedlich das schöne wetter du natürlich
sein
sind aber eben nicht nur jugendliche
gekommen wie sonst zu den freitags demos
sind diesmal auch viele erwachsene dabei
und das soll auch so weitergehen
verwandten aufgefunden
ganze von fern und
haben sich mit angeschlossen
kindern mit den jungen
für eine bessere zukunft für die kunden
es geht nämlich
die welt zu wenden
nicht aus
es ist toll
der grund dafür
[Musik]
die schon
das dann
[Musik]
es sind laufen anstalt
freilich demonstrieren ich habe schon
sehr früh
aber auch ältere menschen eltern mit
kindern sehr viel los die polizei
das nach außen lassen
wir verlieren
und der umzug ist in vor
[Musik]
ich habe bürgermeister seit 30 jahren
bekannt ist was passiert und halt nichts
getan wird dass es immer so weitergeht
und die umwelt irgendwie da nicht so
wichtig ich bin dafür dass jeder
einzelne jedes individuum von sich aus
die schritte macht dies machen muss
damit wir das klima retten und das ist
für mich kein fleisch konsum mehr am
besten direkt vegan also also soweit es
möglich ist für die leute vegan zu
werden vor allem gerade mache ich mir
gedanken
oder viele gedanken über die zukunft
weil ich schwanger bin und ich mein kind
zur welt bringen werde und mich frage in
was für eine welt setzt dieses kind
eigentlich und ich kann nicht zu hause
hocken und so geschehen lassen weil ich
verantwortung unter meinem herzen
praktisch trage
auch thema dass sich die politiker heute
treffen klimaziele auf den weg zu
bringen
aber ganz ehrlich die demonstranten
rechne nicht damit dass von den
politikern besonders bekommt sie glauben
dass alle mit anpacken müssen
man redet darüber was man merkt halt
gerade wenn man sich gewisse politiker
anguckt das ist ein glücklicher ernst
nehmen die welt retten
das kann man nicht in so einem satz
beantworten aber alles was wir tun
können und alles was auch
kommunalpolitiker tun können autofreie
innenstädte mehr für den fahrradverkehr
tun jeder persönlich was machen
da wäre schon geholfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]